okay Donald Trump has been speaking in
Poland over the last 24 or so hours a
press conference a very very warm
reception which I'll explain to you in a
little bit he also gave a speech that
was basically indistinguishable from a
Saturday Night Live parody of his
speeches and it had a particularly
strange section about North Korea if
you've been following what's up with
North Korea they two days ago launched a
missile which experts say has a range
potentially capable of reaching Alaska
and Trump sort of made threats but it
was hard to understand exactly what he
was talking about and he just sounds
like a little kid listen to this section
of the speech about North Korea not only
must we secure our nations from the
threat of terrorism but we must also
confront the threat from North Korea and
that's what it is as a threat and we
will confront it very strongly president
Duda and I call on all nations to
confront this global threat and publicly
demonstrate to North Korea that there
are consequences for their very very bad
behavior as far as North Korea is
concerned I don't know we'll see what
happens I don't like to talk about what
I have planned but I had some pretty
severe things that were thinking about
that doesn't mean we're going to do them
I don't draw red lines very strongly
very very bad behavior very severe
things that we're thinking out thinking
about he sounds like an inexperienced
parent trying to school the
five-year-old right you've been very
very bad and I'm thinking about doing
some really severe things to you it's
perfectly fine to condemn North Korea
for the missile strike but you're
walking on thin ice whenever you do it
so maybe you shouldn't use such
patronizing language like they better
behave and maybe stick to the
teleprompter when it comes to that not
only that he also said I'm not going to
tell I'm not going to say in advance
what we're thinking of doing but we are
thinking of doing some very very severe
things but that doesn't mean we're
actually going to do them and that
exactly leadership language right what
is happening in Trump's brain when he
gives these speeches is he thinking
about
all for maybe Myka and Joe or what's
going on with their engagement it's just
very he doesn't seem to be there really
and there are serious questions about
North Korea as Pat is pointing out I've
been talking about North Korea for years
it's a real problem and we're not trying
to deny that and and the questions that
we're dealing with seem to be way above
Trump's pay grade and by that I mean his
intellectual capacity we've got the
possibility of more sanctions which will
probably do nothing I must China
participate since they've become this
sort of lifeline for North Korea
you've got Russia and China together in
their refusal to really take out North
Korea diplomatically and that will
likely make it difficult for the United
States to unilaterally change the status
quo in North Korea there actually might
have to be some kind of engagement with
North Korea and I know that in many
American circles sort of nationalist
pride prevents people from even
considering that as a viable option but
North Korea is a nuclear State North
Korea is going to continue being a
nuclear state by all indications and
they appear to be making progress in
terms of developing intercontinental
ballistic missiles that could deliver a
nuclear strike so the US policy for a
long time has been no engagement with
North Korea we don't reward bad behavior
we'd basically be saying oh you went
against everything we wanted you to do
and you've developed these what you've
obtained weapons and you're developing
missiles and now we're going to talk to
you it's sort of seen as we're not going
to reward bad behavior but you've got to
rethink pragmatically right at some
point sort of like with Cuba you might
have to do something the Cuban embargo
was to fight communism we're going to
destroy communism through the embargo
decades went by and nothing happened and
then then we realize we're really just
hurting citizens in Cuba and we also
potentially are hurting American
businesses that would want to establish
hotels or businesses or whatever the
case is there what I can assure you that
we don't want is for our national
security to hinge more and more on a
effectively a penis size contest between
Donald Trump and Kim jong-un two of the
most erratic and petty world leaders in
a long time that we don't want what we
do want is probably not
clear to Trump and when we have this
conversation about potential impeachment
of Donald Trump you know a lot of people
may think that Mike Pence would be
certainly worse on some issues
domestically or on social policy but I
would trust his finger on the button a
lot more so than this madman here when
it comes to what we're talking about
right now and this is not me singing the
praises of depraved ideologue Mike Pence
by any means I would be less worried
about a sort of irrational and petty
escalation with Kim jong-un if it's Mike
Pence in the Oval Office than Donald
Trump yeah I guess that we've at least
found an area where we would we would
rather Pence over Trump this is serious
stuff you know and this work I'm
thinking of very very severe things it's
like a little kid is in the Oval Office
which is basically what we're dealing
with send me your thoughts about this
I'm on Twitter at the Pakman the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show
today's program sponsored in part by tag
adapt the hosting specialists whether
you need dedicated server solutions
virtual private servers cloud server
options custom server solutions
colocation services whatever you need
for your business or project tag a gab
and their expert hosting specialists and
support will set you up with what works
for your business or project and their
hosting services support a really wide
range of customers and businesses around
the world including bloggers tech
startups financial traders gamers web
developers and more you can use the code
TDPS
20 to get a twenty british pound credit
towards cloud server options at signup
tag adapt calm /td PS with that you can
try out their services and save twenty
British pounds about twenty three twenty
four US dollars you use the code TDPS
twenty at signup ta ga da be calm /td PS
check it out